5ジャズ search 立っ鉄平
華城ベイトもらえのじゃあー
あああああ
皆さんご存知かは分からないんですけども私ところ座という熊野でかいできる3を買っ
ておりまして金子でもし5年くらいずっと家に置いてあったんですけどもそのところ山
のぬいぐるみがいろいろありまして
[音楽]
竜空へ風になってしまいました
fax ではありません歯結構困っておりますので料理中ではまず本当にマジでないん
ですよね加工いろんな情報を入れたんですけども
結論から言いますとえっと現在知らない女性の方の家に所沢があるみたいでございます
どうすればいいなぁ結構ヤバくない受け
クヴィックよ一応出てユーロ調べましてどういう流れでそうなったのかというのは買っ
たのでちょっとそれだけ説明させて頂きますとまず何が起きたかと言いますと
チェイス蹴上が tb さんの帰宅でボクシング人分でオークションで練習したんです
ねしました入ってその時にケースでも寝床として
ベッドというかご深くと寝るレンチ的な役割として所沢をボクシングジムに持って行き
ましたと本番の大会までところずっと切っていただいておいだったんですけども
ボクシングの圭佑は試合が終わったあともうなかなかちょっと取りに行くタイミングと
か逃しちゃって取りにいかなくて
所沢ちょっと置いてあったメス別床のボクシング自分でしばらくして矢部
とこ
おざなこと忘れてたということになって box んで自分に連絡したところ
ジムの会長さんが曰くこの自分に通ってたボクサーの方に上げてしまったということに
なっているようでございます何気超能力っていうとするそれに行かなかった我々が
もちろん悪いですはいこれ間違いなく僕たちが割れでございます
が我々のところがは開始しに行こうと言ったところを自分の会長さんが他の人にあげて
しまっていたところで
に連絡してところがある返してもらえますかねと言ったところ
もうちょっと上げてしまったからどうしようもないと会場さん的にもあげちゃって
しまったものなんでもどうしようもないっていう
56 nyan 2枚じゃあ悲しくはない
まずかやったらいいねこれであると思うよねたぶん3会長は上田たちのユーチューバー
のことを知らないから
ナースところ座のクマもうただの動画で使った後頭部の一つだと思ったから
それぞれに来てくれないんだったらあげちゃおっかなーみたいな感じで開けちゃったと
思うんですよねあの言わせてくださいボクシングジムの会長は何も悪くありません
悪いノア
トレーニングなかった僕たちですっていうので僕たーーーーの方に所沢が映ってしまっ
て box さあの方の嫁さん
女性の方に所沢が譲渡さで今その女性の方の家にあるというところまででございます
どうしよを取り返したいけどあげちゃってるからさ
正直何とも言えんよね連絡もつかないところが実態ですねそう
会長に行ったところやっぱ会長もあげちゃったから開始前っていうのもちょっとすごい
申し訳ないじゃないですか
確かにねだからちょっと連絡先とかももらえずに連絡先もらえないのやばい
走ろう版ないんだどっ
その開通学校私た朴さんが方もわからないし
唯一ヒントがあるとしたらそのと講座を今持ってる女性の方は twitter が
あったんですよでつ一環みたら所沢バンバン粒やはりですねハッ果たしずでところが来
た腕になっててそんな方が持ってるのはわかってるんですけどもなんかその人もついた
dm とができない状態なんでね今どうちょっと
連絡とらない状況
にありますというところまでございます会長さんらしい寄せてくれたのと動くな
教えてくれなかったんでボクサーの人来た時にこの僕のような企画はたしてその曲げる
ナーゲルでどこにある買っても知りたいんで
説明をして
きたらとしてくださいではたしたんですけど
一週間くらいじゃないですね
それをくれないね多分て我々としましてはもう明って競ったんだったらもう正直あげる
でいいんですよ
まあ帰ってくれれば一番いいんですけどねそれに会社の2つの言わないしていいんです
けど知らない人にあげっていうのはにわたってます
上げるのであればそのあげる方とちゃんとまたしたいしそういうところでちょっと連絡
つかないなっていうのは今一番ネックになっているところです
自分に連絡先を教えてって言ってもこないのであれば我々の手で自らねなくて打ったら
いいです
じゃあどうするも様さーんところで持っている女性がフロントに連絡してみる
直接木グレーと思う dena がボディだったらディップだねぇ
ただこれやり食べないのがねえちょっともさんはされ騒いじゃうんだよ目立つしてなん
かそのヒットさ火が行くのも嫌なんですよ
だから本当は dm でこっそりするのがいいんですけどそれもできない状況にあるの
で穴塗っている
いやーの圭佑のマナー何度肇社長三戦のところかキョンいただいてしまいましたはじめ
はざんげちゃんでだんだんの顔やう
ボクシング自分に所沢考えて会長と仲の良いだったに譲ってくれたそうです
しかしデカイ困ったなぁただ上げるのであればよちゃん
としてあげたいというところでございます我が父のサーバーができます
候補
ってけどパワーをやばみんなの上に爆弾こわいけどでも全裸って手段はこれしかないよ
すごくさあの人もわかんないし握手ジブリでしょ
まあ最初で4歳だけがこれだと思いますいきます
ています
あああああやばいん
これで池松か今連絡を待ちます
越冬そのところ山で持ち主の女性の方と連絡が
されました俺ましたお忙しいなかご連絡ありがとうございます
ここの舗装テープ受けしていますで所沢の件なんですが私の手違いによりあなたの格好
にわたってしまっていると伺いしております
ボクシングジムの会長様に十分な説明していなかったこちらのミスで申し訳ないんです
が
ところ竿外出いただけることは可能でしょうか
もちろんでした jica さーん
イースターって感じだったんですね申し訳ないんですがとこだザクの輪ゴムをとって
しまいましたごめんね
あれ何本なんかにづらいかっていうとこの人がすごい喜んで聞いて来られるのか
結構させたことを起こしててがめっちゃ喜んでるなぁと思って帰ってくださいというの
はとても言いづらい状況にありますか
えっ入ってずっとブーバー今持ってるパティイクーッ
あとってます
まちこさんですか非常にツイッターめっちゃ楽しそうでなんかもう避けなかったですよ
ね
これがあったんやったら
大変でしょこれねめっちゃも行ってみ町内ん
あなたなんかもう勝手に待つ区間なところが気に入ってきてもう絶対返したくないのか
なっていう妄想版ですよね
みましょう当然ちゃうんだろまあ寂しいですけどそういうめちゃくちゃ
これは本当ですか
[音楽]
ていたところだった
言われたんですよあ
タイトルと無人ところ像が帰ってきました
浅いというわけで無事ところ像が帰ってきました
reit だったねめっちゃ人だったですね
ブーストだったけれどもやっぱり知らないと手に渡っている不安がすごかったですねー
声はい
受けて帰ります
me
あっはぁ